okay so
what six months ago you told me you have
a cool
aggressive oh yeah i've been saving this
for a long time
yeah yeah i've been working on uh you're
going to play the stafford obviously i
mean this is are you going to drink your
like i'm going to refute it okay and i'm
going to ruin your career destroy your
opening i think many people have tried
but i'm going to do it all right i'm
going to refute the stafford right now i
hate to bring it to you and the stopper
is over
all right let me go so basically though
too i also don't uh the thing is i don't
want to actually refute an opening the
same way that everybody does i want to
make like a pointless reputation because
you know what i'm a gambit guy too i
love a good gambit everyone loves a good
gambit uh and so i want to play
something that's actually like equal
according to the computer i just want
the initiative i want something easy to
play for white i want the initiative i
don't know if we'll get it there's a lot
of things you might play so i actually
don't know what you're gonna do we'll
see if we can get it we'll see if we can
just have a fun game okay i don't know
whether to be terrified or absolutely
see what you have
oh
you know i have a bunch of a lot of
things i know i know
all right i actually don't know what
you're gonna play here
okay i'll play where they usually play
okay
knight d5 is a little bit better
yeah again there's a lot of options
i'm not sure how deeply you've studied
this i'm kind of
kind of scared
triple forward
what did you think
okay
castle too
still not
i'm jealous of your king because i'm
higher than me
i think we're both having fun
i'm not scared of checks
are you sure
check ah check
now your king supports d4
this is my plan all along
made a threat
i thought i made a threat
just being very sneaky
oh you choose congratulations
okay so treat this as a cabinet i guess
yeah
boy
honestly keeping this h3
so
i mean now that your career is ruined i
don't know what you're gonna do for the
rest of your life
it's not ruined in toy actually
then it'll be ruined
okay
school rooms out of five
just gonna be a little careful
let's do something
did your job
somebody checks this game let's add to
it
check it
out
i would want king of the hill 3 check
i'm trying to win every game possible
oh no
oh no
you only swindle me
check
that was much safer
so
it's gonna get intense
i don't know how it's gonna end it's
gonna be crazy
game foreign i'm the opening guy i don't
never played in that game in my life
actually
okay
so
check
this
is
promoted so fast
could have made it easy i made it hard
stay away
i thought i was being tricky and then i
was out of peace but i was tricky back
but then i was gone
i thought rookie 3 was wrong
yeah and i even saw this in my mind i'm
like i
rejected it immediately because you
could just push right and i thought
about it longer and i did it anyway
so
separated pawns like this yeah against
the king is usually a theoretical draw
even if you don't have a pawn here
yeah but
it's hard to defend yeah
bye youtube